what do you say to screenwriters that
are afraid someone will steal either
their idea or their finished script this
is really so unsexy get over it
it's it really there really is nothing
for the industry to gain from stealing
work if you're a brand-new writer and
you wrote something that is the greatest
idea ever the industry is much better
off you're not a WJ member buying that
script from you for 25 grand 30 grand
maybe 50 grand and doing whatever they
want to with it as opposed to
potentially getting tied up in lawsuits
it really doesn't pay anybody to steal
work in the industry and you can't come
at the industry from a place of mistrust
you can't come at agents and managers
saying well I've sent you my work but
I'm really nervous because I've heard
about how scripts get stolen because
then you're coming added from a place of
I automatically do not trust you the
industry I am the writer you're going to
victimize me nobody wants to work with
that nobody wants to deal with that and
the reality is that when bridesmaids
came out I can't tell you how many
writers came to me and said oh my god I
wrote that exact same script there are
ideas that are zeitgeist II their ideas
that are in the moment and those ideas
tend to manifest in many different
places but it really does not serve you
in any way to think that the industry
will steal your work your job with your
script that you have if you're writing
outside of the industry and all
likelihood if you have a feature script
the job of that feature script is to get
you an agent to get you a manager that's
its job it likely won't sell as it is to
the industry we're in in this industry
the 2016 we are likely to sell less than
a hundred specs that's not a big number
if you're aiming for that bull's eye
that is a narrow narrow narrow bull's
eye you want to use that script to get
you an agent to get you a manager to
introduce you to the industry to get on
the prestige lists that's what you want
that's great to do for you and in order
to do that you have to expose the work
so get over any idea that somebody will
steal your script because that's just
not going to happen and in the rare rare
rare rare occasions that it has the
writer usually got their their own
success in their own way
well let's continue with mistrust
because I think on your screen writing
blog for your website Lee Jessup comm
you have a post entitled screenwriters
leave your mistress at the door mhm and
I know some of us are way more trusting
than others summer may be more on the
naive scale but you talked about some
some things that a lot of people I think
would be afraid of like they want me to
sign a release form I mean that's scary
that's that's a little scary or I think
this one we're kind of touching on that
screenplay has the same concept of mind
somebody stole my idea wouldn't they
rather cheat me than pay me so how do
you work with someone that's already
coming with those set of fears and make
them so that they're a little more
workable but not naive not not a doormat
I always tell my writers that I'm the
same the safe space so you can let out
all your neuroses and I'll put you in
your place so I actually wrote that
particular blog post after a writer of
mine had finished a script the script
had made had had been entered into one
contest hadn't placed and another script
with eerie similarities sold eerie eerie
eerie similarities and the writer came
to me and said what am I to make of this
and we had to kind of sit back and say
okay here's where the script was here's
the writer who just sold a script
here's there is no as much as I
understand there eerie similarities
let's talk through what the probability
would be of this writer an established
writer with a summer blockbuster would
have of stealing your script let's talk
through it so I always tell my writers
on the safe space we need to talk about
it but at some point a writer either
wises up or not so I worked with a
writer for a while that I no longer work
with who refused to pitch any ideas talk
loglines or anything as such in a public
environment so in a coffee shop in a bar
which is where a lot of industry
meetings take place mind you the writer
refused to do it because somebody would
listen and somebody would still a steal
his idea and it became uncomfortable and
so at some point I had to say to the
writer
listen you're gonna have managers
meeting you there was a manager that
wanted to meet with that writer in a
coffee shop so the manager is gonna ask
you what else do you have what are you
gonna say I can't tell you here I'll
send you an email it doesn't work that
way so at some point even if you have it
innately you have to set it aside you
have to because this industry works the
way that it does with the idea of trust
and respecting the creative mind the
creative brain the originator of content
if you originated a great idea a great
script a great story why would I steal
it from you why wouldn't I just take the
thing that's already done and do
something with it wouldn't that make
more sense for me if I'm a producer an
executive why would I steal it get
somebody else to write it potentially
for more money because they are already
well-known either they executed well or
they don't maybe they don't or somebody
else does the same thing before my
script is done why would they just pick
it up from you the creator of content
who came up with this great content what
incentive do I and executive have to
steal it from you and that's what a lot
of writers have to despite how
frustrating it can get have to look at
and that's ultimately what that writer
and myself had to look at when a script
with eerie similarities to his sold
there was no way for the manager who
sold the script to get that script there
was no way that an industry executive
had read that script it had been
submitted to one place three months
before there was just no no reality in
which the script was stolen rewritten
what the writer had to acknowledge was
that ultimately if I'm the manager right
behind the script sale and I hear I got
let's let's assume I got a completed
script that is great that I think I can
sell and I have this writer who just had
a box-office success what is my best way
of making the most money my best way of
making the most money is getting the one
script that I just got that's ready to
sell and selling it and booking my
writer who just had a big box-office
success on a writing assignment and
making more money why limit the ways in
which I'm making money by having the
writer then take the script and try to
make money off of it rather than
monetize both so
those are the equations that writers
have to look at isn't really an
industry's best interest to steal
content I really don't find that it is
you